on behalf of facts at research systems
we are very happy to be sponsoring this
morning session we were very happy once
again to be a part of the nave Annual
Meeting particularly this 50-year
celebration given the events going on
right now in the economy in the markets
in the political arena we all know that
this is the place to be this week so now
without further ado I'd like to have
Catherine Mann introduce today's
prestigious speakers thank you very much
I don't want to take any time and I
don't think these speakers need any
introduction but just in case you've
just crawled out from underneath a rock
and you don't know who these people are
let me give you a couple of sentences on
each one I will give the introductions
in the order in which they will speak on
the topic first of course is Edmund s
felts he is McVicar professor of
political economy at Columbia University
and he is director of Columbia's center
on capitalism and society and of course
is the winner of the ninth 2006 Nobel
Prize for economics among the additional
awards he has received this year he was
also named Chevalier of the Legion of
Honour won the Premio Pico della
Mirandola
prized for humanism and the Kiel global
economy prize his research has spanned
economic growth including the golden
rule of savings micro economic
foundations of inflation and employment
dynamics structuralist models of
unemployment determination dynamism and
inclusion for in capitalist and
corporatists systems and the good
economy our second speaker is Paul
Krugman he has at least three jobs he's
professor of economics and international
affairs at Princeton University
he is centenary professor at the London
School of Economics and perhaps of
course he is best well-known for his job
as an op-ed a column
a columnist for The New York Times he's
been called the most important political
economist in America and by others he is
Nobel bound Krugman is best known for
his work in the area of international
trade and finance at least that's to us
economists perhaps he's best well-known
for that and in recognition of that
award and work he received the John
Bates Clark award medal from the
American economics Association most
recently has also received what is
called the European Pulitzer Prize the
prince of asturias award given by the
king of Spain so with those very quick
introductions let us first start with
mr. Phelps please good morning it's a
pleasure to be here when I accepted this
invitation it seems like about 12 months
ago I of course I had no idea that we
would be heading into a deep crisis and
its aspects that crisis that I want to
talk about this morning I'd like to
begin with some some of my ideas on the
causes and then move to a recent
discussion I gave of the the Paulson
proposal which is now law and then go on
and in a few remaining minutes to touch
on the sort of basic reform and radical
restructuring that we might want to do
in the financial sector
I think its crisis has taught us all
kinds of lessons but for me as a macro a
common macro economist in macroeconomic
theorists one of the towering lessons is
that it is made obvious to all but the
most doctrinaire academics that night he
and uncertainty
prevails in the economy and when a novel
kind of shock arises or a series of
shocks there's a spike spike up in the
level of night in uncertainty no this
this this night in uncertainty about
what the parameters of the economy are
and perhaps even what this current state
of the economy is presents all kinds of
problems for monetary policy which would
take us to far afield today but if you
think about the Taylor rule it's it's it
writes down an equation to get the
policy interest rate but almost
everything in the right hand side of the
equation is unknown and they call that
rules I don't know what they would mean
by discretion but thanks and yet so much
of macroeconomics is written as if the
structure is known and also constant so
like what we might call neo-keynesian x'
many of them at least have accepted the
idea of a natural unemployment rate for
example a Taylor rule but they take the
natural unemployment rate even if they
define that as some sort of medium-term
level of the unemployment rate to which
the economy is supposed to ten they they
take that natural unemployment rate to
be a constant a deep parameter of the
system but a lot of my work in the late
80s and over much of the 90s attempted
to argue that that this medium term
natural unemployment rate
is not a constant it must be taken
thought of as a variable just write down
any non-monetary model and with any kind
of luck you'll see that your natural
unemployment rate is responsive to
wealth real interest rates real exchange
rates as well as all the underlying
state variables and most of the assorted
of their parameters now this brings up
the the what the the rollercoaster we've
been through in the nineteen late 1990s
or sorry well thinking about the late
1990s the Internet boom led me to think
about structural booms and I argued
towards the end of that episode in in
2000 that we had that the economy had
gone through what was a sort of an
effective reduction of the natural
unemployment rate as a result of the
expectations encouraged by the internet
revolution so we can have an
extraordinarily low unemployment rate in
in the second half of the 90s lower than
any lower than the the true blue a
natural unemployment rate without having
inflation because relative prices and
interest rates and everything else were
reshaped by the new set of expectations
regarding the profitability of various
kinds of investments in the internet the
housing boom in the in the first in the
years let's say by one measure would be
I suppose 2002 to 2007 or you could go
back farther
to 1997 the housing boom is rather
different because there was a a false
note and in that structural boom a good
chunk of the expectations were
groundless you might say that with
regard to the cumulative rise of in in
the real price of houses between 1997
and and and 2007 or so about 70 percent
will prove to be sustainable be a
reasonable guess but 30% has to be
unwound so that's a different kind of
structural boom you get it you got a
huge change in relative prices but much
of that change in relative prices was
not sustainable so the first thing to
say from a macroeconomic point of view
about the the about the recent situation
is that we saw an end to the to the
expectation of disequilibrium which had
been imparting a temporary negative
effect or downward effect on the
effective natural unemployment rate
expectations are always rosy than the
relative price of houses is always too
high and that means construction is too
high and the effective natural
unemployment rate is too low it sits
below the true natural unemployment rate
so with the return of sanity and the
decline in the relative in the real
price of houses over the past 18 or 24
months
there is going to be a rise back up to
some sort of normal level in the
structural volume of unemployment which
we did see but of course a lot more was
going on
just that besides the structural impact
of the drop in the real price of houses
on the level of economic activity in
terms of any kind of real non-monetary
model besides that there was also the
heritage of an overhang of in houses
that if they were to be lived in would
be bought only at prices below the cost
of production so this overhang of houses
from the the previous exuberance is a
distinct further contractionary effect
but it's transient because the overhang
will eventually be worked off so besides
getting back in through purely
structural structural mechanisms back to
the true natural unemployment rate
through the correction and the relative
price of houses you're going to have a a
loop around a loop a rise of
unemployment before you get a fall of
the unemployment in the course of the
adjustment to the overhang then finally
you have the the overhang of toxic
assets bad paper in the banking system
left by the over exuberance of the
housing boom and
I struggled with that for a while let me
see what I can find
alt-tab ha and well let me talk about
Figure one for a minute here so you see
here you see point a you see it no okay
a point a there we were in some
hypothetical year point at Point a we
were at the natural unemployment level
and then expectations of a new plateau
for the real price of houses elicited a
jump in the actual price of houses from
that given by point a to that given by
point B with that high price of houses
the construction industry was
electrified and and house construction
proceeded at an abnormal rate the stock
of houses rose then at points C if all
had gone well if all had gone well we
would have ended up at a we would have
joined the blue line and then from the
blue line we would have proceeded with
stately grace to a prime but that's not
what happened we came to realize that
the expectations were false there was a
crisis at C the price of houses then has
to drop to D and then because the stock
of houses is too large the stock of
houses has to reduce to C and in the
course of that construction is
abnormally low now mm-hmm I was coming
to the matter of the effects of the
situation in the banking system how to
think about that in structural terms
does that mean a ride that it is there a
structural we we don't need to get hung
up about what we mean precisely by the
natural unemployment right here just put
it this way does the does the the the
the bad assets the illiquidity the
uncertainty surrounding the bad assets
the bad paper in the banking system does
that have any kind of structural
repercussions that's important because
if it exerts a structural impact
unemployment decreasing causing
structural volume of employment to
decrease then that's not something that
we could necessarily want to look to the
monetary policy to look to monetary
policy to address well my argument is
that it does have a structural impact
let me bring you back to the the kind of
diagram that underlay figure one there's
a medium-term supply curve it tells you
what the stock of the business asset
convenience asset you want stock a
customer's stock of employees stock of
plant
so what mmm tells you what would happen
at any given real price of the asset q2
the stock k the larger q the larger
ultimately k will be k could also be
houses and then the demand price is the
blue is the blue curve i won't stop to
tell you why it's upward sloping instead
of downward sloping but it has to do
with relative factor by relative factor
intensities and stuff like that it's
easy but it just won't take the time
with it so what is the effect of the of
the banking mess on this there on the
structural aspects of this hypothetical
economy not all of which is captured
fully in the diagram of course I ended
it introduces an uncertainty premium an
uncertainty premium that somebody has to
pay so to speak and and as I see it
introduced
at least one of the effects of this
uncertainty premium is to drive a wedge
between the demand price and the supply
price and that wedge reduces the stock
of business assets that businesses will
ultimately be willing to hold and on the
way down you're going to have reduced
investment activity reduced investment
in commercial real estate reduced
investment in customers we could take
time to figure out what that means
reduced investment in new employees it's
obvious what that means and and so and
this non-monetary perspective does then
predict that there will be a slump in
the economy as a response as a result of
the presumably temporary overhang of bad
paper in the banking system
now one of my manuscripts is disappear
almost an ideal chairman chairwoman
chairperson now mm-hmm
enter the Paulsen plan what to say about
the Paulsen plan
well again I I tend to try what as long
as I can to maintain my structuralist
viewpoint on things and
I I say first of all that there are two
problems
presented by the banking crisis one is
the illiquidity that the 19 uncertainty
has caused to the vet the nighty and
uncertainty about the value of the
assets on the banks books has caused and
and that has caused counterparties lend
to who might otherwise have lent to
banks banks who might have lent during
the course of the day to other banks
will will be nervous about lending
because they don't know the financial
state of the bank that wants to borrow
from them and and that's caused a
freezing up of credit as well as you all
as you all know now the the most famous
part of the Paulson plan of course is to
have the Treasury step in and do
something it's faintly reminiscent of a
open market purchase in which the
Treasury will buy the toxic assets from
the banks paying with cash same time the
Treasury will finance that by selling
Treasuries on the open market and so in
effect it's an exchange of Treasury
securities for toxic assets the Treasury
securities are liquid so the banks will
be liquefied again presumably there
won't be anymore a counter party risk
and so forth
the main point let me just say that I
wrote about this subject in in last
Wednesday's Wall Street Journal
case you want to read further about
about my views the main point I made
about about this part of the Paulsen
plan is that well two points really
first of all I express concern that the
the once prices are established for
these toxic assets they will be found to
be lower than what the bank's already
recognized on their balance sheets for
that very reason some banks will be
unwilling to sell the assets they they
won't they won't want to see those
assets being valued on their way out the
door at reduced prices which will mean
they get less lessen means which means
they get that much less in return for
those assets and so they won't it just
won't be willing to play ball especially
when they're told that they'll CEO have
to take wage salary cuts in order to
participate in this plan so there are
lots of reasons to think that this that
that the Paulson plan won't succeed in
cleaning up the balance sheets anytime
quickly of the second point is that
incident in so far as the the Paulson
plan does Coke's assets bad paper out of
the banks the consequent accounting
losses the consequent recognition of
further losses on that assets will only
aggravate the second problem that the
banks have namely that they are quasi
insolvent
the losses will will will add to the
will subtract from the excess if any of
assets over liabilities so capital
equity will be reduced so it is very is
indeed very important that the plan make
provision for an infusion of new equity
into the banks particularly since step
one of the process is going to going to
aggravate the insolvency problem now in
the Wall Street Journal piece I run my
hands a little bit in anxiety over
whether this means that the evils of
corporatism which I like to lecture
about sternly in recent years whether
that means that the evils of corporatism
are now at the door of the united states
government the United States government
will be going around the country
deciding which banks are to receive
equity infusions and which which not and
god knows what sort of mischief might
come out of that but now I realized that
it could be done in a way that would not
require the exercise of any discretion
when secretary Paulson visits the bank
and decides on and and they decide how
much the bank is going to sell of it in
the way of toxic assets to the Treasury
and that number is decided upon then
that then Paulson can ask us a ask his
aide to give him the corresponding
equity infusion that the bank will be
entitled to having sold that much equity
paper so it could be automated so there
would be no discretion at all
it was the equity infusion and the
purchase of toxic assets would come
together together
side by side let me finish up in the
next two minutes I don't have a crystal
ball I don't know how well this this
rescue plan is going to succeed it may
very well be and that we will need a
second rescue plan I hope that I hope
but I do help of course I hope that the
plan will succeed because we don't want
to open the panda open Pandora's box to
all sorts of uncertain and probably in
many cases badly badly conceived
ill-judged alternative policy measures
but let's hope we can look forward to
the time in the not-too-distant future
when we'll have the leisure to be able
to sit down and think about how to
restructure the financial sector not so
a mess not so that a mess like this can
never happen as long as we have a
capitalist system with its inherent
uncertainties and its considerable
amount of risk-taking of course there
are going to be there is always going to
be the possibility of a of crisis and
catastrophe if you will but it seems
obvious that there are major ways in
which we have to rethink the financial
sector one of them is to get away from
this notion that that contrary to
impression there is certainty in the
world of finance plus or minus a random
disturbance term and all we need is to
have is the wonderful deterrent
stochastic models of a financial
engineering risk assessment and and at
risk
management - to cope with these little
stochastic fluctuations we have to get
around that and one way to get around
that is to make sure that all of
institutional judgments about assets
always consist of at least two numbers
the good case and the bad case and I was
thinking that that principle could be
extended rather widely the second thing
is certainly we need to have improved
corporate governance in the in the banks
my goodness the I don't know what the
boards of directors have been doing in
recent years to allow somewhat just
shenanigans to go on and the third and
last point I would make is that I don't
think we've noticed that something
really strange has happened to the
banking industry and I don't know I
can't put a date on when it happened but
I know that there was a time not an
economic historian but I know there was
a time when let's say in 1871 I saw the
plaque not long ago in Berlin the
Deutsche Bank what would would lend and
invest to businesses for investment and
for innovation thoughtyou Bank was one
of the indirectly one of the financial
sources of support for the Alva Edison
company whatever happened to those times
when we expected investment banks to
lend to business instead it seems to be
that they they the the the the these
banks lend primarily for residential
mortgages to some extent for commercial
mortgages and and some commercial paper
and that's it
you wonder how business investment and
business innovation can be financed and
a friend of Mines has started looking
into that and dug out some numbers and
it's it's it's it's all it's it's not
even venture capital venture capital is
something like two-tenths of one percent
of all investment
in the economy it's negligible just a
handful of guys in Silicon Valley it's
mostly rich uncle's called angel
investors and venture capitalists who
come on late in the growth of a new
company and and private equity firms
we've got to if we're going to have a
return or we're gonna have a return to
economic dynamism in the American
economy we've got to have a healthy
banking industry that serves investment
and innovation in the business sector
thank you I was a good good combination
of first comparing the internet boom
with the housing boom I guess the
internet boom was better because it
actually produced something and when all
that fiber was really cheap it asked
ACTA to cheap input to a lot of other
businesses and then our second issue
being with regard to a successful
Paulsen banking plan either we have to
overpay for those banking assets those
toxic assets in order to get them out of
the banking system or else we have to
take equity positions the government has
to take or us have to take equity
positions in all of those banks which I
think ideologically a number of people
have a problem with government ownership
of banks so we've you know we've set up
some interesting topics for our
questions and now please turn to Paul
Krugman so good morning
so thanks that interesting times um so I
am I took my charge
I took the title of the session
seriously and said I should do something
global which turned out to be a good
topic a good a good direction to go
right now and actually the the first
slide I had here aha all right just try
turns out to be unnecessary I took year
52 week changes in various stock indices
to demonstrate that we actually have a
linked financial crisis globally but you
don't need that chart if you looked at
the news this morning you know that it's
kind of actually amazing right we have a
crisis that basically starts with
Florida condos and and California
McMansions and it's led to the
government of Greece feeling it has to
guarantee all bank deposits it's it's
spreading internationally to an
extraordinary extent this is it is very
quickly becoming a an internationalized
global financial crisis even though the
origins seem to lie in the United States
and that's an interesting point it I
think it helps us focus on on what is
really going on here and it's a new
version of international linkages of
contagion I want to talk a little bit
about what we think is going on here now
there is a traditional view about how
international macroeconomic linkages
work and it's a it's a view that runs in
terms of trade flows flows of goods and
services the foreign trade multiplier is
the way it was when what taught when I
was in grad school the idea was well is
a slump in the United States that leads
to lower US imports lower US imports are
lower exports for other countries that
then has a multiplier effect on their
economies and then they shrink and that
has a some some rebound effect on the
United States and so we have this kind
of linkage almost a physical linkage
physics flows of goods now its flows of
services as well but there's stuff we
buy less stuff from the rest of the
world and that depresses the rest of the
world's economy if it would that were
all that were happening we would be
having some problems certainly it's not
good for Canada to be seeing the United
States slumping it's not good for for
Mexico and it's something of a problem
for China Japan but you wouldn't be
seeing anything like the kinds of
linkages that we're seeing taking place
right now
we're not in some ways that's not a
surprise because we already had a
example of how you can have closely
linked economic crises even though the
trade flow linkages aren't that large
and I these days we I find it hard to
believe that we're now talking about the
you know back in the distant past when
we had this Asian financial crisis that
is a whole decade ago we had this
extraordinary episode of what everyone
was calling at the time global contagion
everyone was talking about the contagion
of the crisis which starts in Thailand
which is a small faraway country of
which we know nothing then spreading to
other Asian countries and eventually
ricocheting in seemingly bizarre ways a
meltdown in Russia is quickly followed
by a speculative attack on Brazil and
for a brief terrifying moment in the
fall of 1998 via the fall of long-term
capital management caused the freezing
up of US markets although these days
what what sieved at the time like a
terrifying shutdown and of liquidity
looks like that was that was nothing
compared to what we've seen now but and
what was really striking about that
crisis was the tightness of the linkages
between countries that are just not that
important as trading partners for each
other so I just a little chart there
this is showing rates of growth of GDP
for the for front line crisis countries
and you know Malaysia is not an
important market for Korea Korea not an
important market for Malaysia and yet
altogether
they experienced a very tightly
coordinated very severe slump which told
you that there's something else going on
here that there's a different form of
linkage in the world economy now you
might say look that was Thailand this
time we're having a slump in the United
States and we're a much bigger player in
the world and so those conventional
trade linkages must be a lot more
important in our case and the the answer
actually though is
there are more important but not a lot
more important that even now even with
all of the globalization and growth of
world trade that's taken place flows of
trade purchase of goods and services
internationally are not big enough to
create by themselves a lot of linkage I
was just checking this this is a
slightly funny way to put it not the way
you usually look at but this is us toll
US imports as a percentage of the rest
of the world's GDP the combined GDP of
all the other countries in the world
it's up it's grown since 1980 but it's
still around 6% so the US imports around
16% of u.s. GDP but we're only a
fraction that the rest of the world is
several times bigger than we are so so
overall our imports are still looking
around 6% of the rest of the world's GDP
to give you a idea suppose we wanted to
have a negative 1% shock to demand in
the rest of the world from the United
States that would mean that we have to
have our imports fall from 6% to 5% of
rest of world GDP which is a more than
15 percent decline we have a rough idea
of what the the GDP elasticity of
imports is it's about 2 so in order to
get that kind of shock and that's just a
1% shock which is considerably less than
what the housing decline has done to the
u.s. to get that you'd have to have a 7
or 8 percent decline in u.s. GDP we
require an enormous recession here to
generate even a fairly modest negative
blow to rest the world demand we might
be getting there but it's it certainly
hasn't I don't think we will I think
it's going to be bad I guess Goldman is
now saying 8 percent unemployment by the
end of next year but but I don't think
it's going to be that bad and in any
case that we're seeing the linkages now
so what is happening well what's clear
is that what we're seeing is linkages
through the financial sector and
particularly through
pressures on highly leveraged institute
of various kinds banks and things that
are like banks a lot of it is things
that are like banks rather than things
that are actually least formally banks
we we have this shadow banking system
now the parallel banking system which
Tim Geithner says is ten trillion
dollars in the u.s. about the same size
as the conventional banking system I
guess that's about right
but even if you look just just at the
banks themselves this I just pulled this
out from the BIS report it does not
include the post Lehman crisis so that's
just showing CDs spreads for banks in
the u.s. essentially the eurozone and
the UK and what's extraordinary aside
from the incredible amount of risk that
people now perceive is the close
coordination even though we have a
crisis that is fundamentally centered in
u.s. mortgage-backed securities it has
afflicted banks all across the all
across the North Atlantic region roughly
equally really really extraordinary so
what's happening here
I've been trying I think along with
every other economist on the planet
trying to do a lot of on-the-fly
modeling trying to make sense of what's
going on here I don't get gonna give you
a slightly obscure picture I'll try to
explain it for a second this is how I
think about it right now I think about
some kind of assets think of it maybe is
well I guess mortgage-backed securities
is more or less what we're talking about
but you can even think of it as being
the housing stock though that's not
quite right and think of there being two
kinds of players yes
we're all into upward sloping demand
curves here okay why why is the demand
from upwards from highly leveraged
institutions upward sloping because of
leverage and and limits on leverage the
higher the price of the assets the more
capital they have the
or that the bigger their balance sheets
can get so the more of this stuff they
can hold the lower the price the less
capital they have the lower their
balance sheets and the this is some kind
of short to medium run story in the in
the very long run people can create new
financial institutions but it doesn't
happen overnight and then you can think
of this demand from sorry supply what
the supply curve is there's a there's a
certain amount of toxic paper out there
some of it is held by people other than
these highly leveraged institutions the
higher the price the less of that these
other guys want to hold and therefore
the more that is available to be bought
or must be bought by the highly
leveraged institutions this kind of
thing by the way it's it's entirely
possible for this thing to be unstable
for you to have the possibility of a
self-fulfilling decline in prices in
which prices cause capital losses for
the highly leveraged institutions which
could lead to sales which lead to a no
and so on it a it collapsed to a a lower
level equilibrium it to sound like a
academic economist that might be
happening now although I have to say
it's not compelling in the numbers it's
not it's not clear that the prices have
gone to levels that are can only be
explained by multiple equilibria so we
could we could try to explain it that
way but for now at least in my current
thinking I prefer to not think of it as
being as self-fulfilling prophecy but
simply as a situation where where there
is a lot of effect of asset prices on
the ability of leveraged institutions to
to to expand or or to the extent to
which they're forced to contract their
balance sheets where this is a really
very strong thing and yes so upward
sloping demand curves do play a big role
so the story of our crisis is something
like this we've had a downward shock the
the collapse of the housing bubble has
led to a decline in the demand for
assets from other investors
also known as real people and so the
real people are are not willing to hold
as much of this stuff at any given price
as they were before which in and of
itself would lead to a decline in asset
prices but then we have this huge
multiplier effect which and I have to
say I I think I called the housing
bubble pretty well but the extent to
which there would be a financial
multiplier has caught me by surprise I
did not realize how much we would have
these highly leveraged institutions
forced into contracting their balance
sheets and how much this would propagate
not not simply be a a burst housing
bubble but a broad abroad widespread
financial crisis okay-y at the bottom
these highly leveraged institutions turn
out to be very much international
investors you have banks in Germany
exposed to the US MBS market you have
banks in the United States exposed to an
important degree to to other markets and
so as a result when you start to have
this thing happening it's not just even
if the the the shock is occurring to
assets initially u.s. mortgage-backed
securities you're getting these capital
losses balance sheet effects
international financial multiplier
spreading across borders it's very much
a globalized process and as we're now
seeing shockingly so even though the
origin of the shock is and basically
largely in the u.s. Sun Belt the the
consequences are spreading to markets
all across the world so the the new view
you might say of international linkages
would look something like this home
sorry that doesn't mean houses that
means I'm folding into international
economies Jharkhand where there are
always two countries which are called
home and foreign so asset prices in in
one country fall that reduces the
capital of highly leveraged institutions
forces them to reduce their to shrink
their balance sheets which takes place
both at home and abroad leads to a fall
prices in the rest of the world and of
course this is actually a loop because
it comes right back to - to home and and
so you get this mutually reinforcing
process it could be a runaway it could
be a vicious circle that just spreads
but even if it isn't it means that
there's a lot of propagation from this
initial negative shock that really
spreads around the world now one
question you might ask is why are we
seeing this now we did not see this to
the same extent as far as I can make
another crazies by the way I should say
that one story about the Asian crisis or
the the world financial crisis of the
late 1990s say you we we thought that
was a crisis now it seems like you know
like a a mild upset stomach it but what
that that thing which took place back in
in 1997 through 1999 there were a number
of stories that were proposed to explain
why we were getting so much contagion
some of it was arguing that it was just
psychological some of it was the the
wake-up call once once Thailand well
went people started you know looking
with a gimlet eye on other emerging
markets some people said that there were
multiple equilibria so that basically
everybody got shocked into the into the
bad state I said that myself but one
story that people were telling was in
fact that about highly leveraged
investors and balance sheets the
argument being that there were
particularly there were hedge funds and
a few banks that were doing much of the
lending and once they took losses in one
place they'd have to cut back elsewhere
so Russia Falls and this puts LTCM in
trouble and they that means a pullback
in Brazil so that was probably some and
there's some evidence that that the
contagion was greater when there were
more of these institutions but now we
have these institutions on a much much
larger scale first of all growth of the
shadow banking system parallel banking
systems so the the range of institutions
that are vulnerable that don't have
they're extremely highly leveraged
because they're they're not under basel
ii and
and are extremely vulnerable because
they don't have deposit insurance that's
not how they do they're at their funding
that's larger than it was and the other
thing which is really striking is just
how much financial globalization has
taken place just recently and so this is
a again slightly odd denominator but I
thought it was useful this is us from
from the u.s. international investment
position u.s. assets abroad foreign
assets in the United States as a
percentage of the rest of the world's
GDP so again the GDP of the world
outside of the United States and as we
all know the United States has become a
debtor country so we've become a country
where our our liabilities exceed our
assets but what's often missed is that
the really big story is the increase on
both sides that we have just a great
deal more both assets and liabilities
that just become a much financial
exposures in the United States financial
exposures by the United States are both
much much larger as a share of the world
than they were and and the big take off
has taken place just since the mid-1990s
so we really have a much more globalized
financial system than we did which means
that that that the world is a lot more
tightly coupled than it used to be means
that you know we always say the big
thing from my finance people that we
needed more global diversification
people should diversify their portfolios
more because that would reduce risk
would get the more ability to spread
risk which may be true for the
individual but what it seems to produce
for the world as a whole is the
possibility of a global financial crisis
in the way that we did not have before
and so and here we are with God knows
what's happened even as Ned and I have
been speaking because it's it's quite a
morning out there what are you doing in
here you should be out there anyway let
me just say a word about about policy I
think I can come back to the
globalization so
Paulson plan everybody knows what I
think about the polls
plan everybody knows what I think about
everything actually guess is my other
job but the things about its you know as
people said that the Treasury was have
was doing a bad job of communicating
about how the plan was supposed to work
but I think the reason for that is that
they have no idea how the plan is
supposed to work
the the the trouble with the Paulson
plan is pretty clearly that they grabbed
hold of the wrong end of the stick that
if we think that our problem is that
this housing bubble burst which is
unavoidable is propagating because of
its effect on the balance sheets of
highly leveraged institutions and and
and therefore forcing further
contraction that the what what you want
what you need to do is is in fact to to
recapitalize this financial system so I
think that's what everybody has
converged on that is saying it I'm
saying it did the real problem is is now
that that capital has been destroyed and
and and needs to be added and the
Poulsen plan instead of coming in with
more capital and said so we're going to
buy up some of these bad assets with no
explanation of how that was supposed to
help if you pay the prices that the
current market prices for those for the
toxic waste
you don't improve the capital all you do
is you you know there's a lot of people
were saying well we need to get those
toxic assets off the off the banks
balance sheets well you know anybody can
get those toxic assets off the balance
sheet just write them down to zero and
poof they're gone but that doesn't help
you any because if that worsens your
capital position the question was at
what price do you get them off the
balance sheets and if you get them off
the prices that they're currently going
for 22 cents on the dollar or whatever
you haven't done any you haven't helped
at all now maybe you know then they
there's some argument that maybe because
the fire sale nature of what's going on
the prices are too low and we can you
know break it out by doing something
differently but that's that's not at all
clear and what they should have been
doing and I think what we will
eventually do tarp to will will in fact
be an injection of cap
it will require something like
large-scale purchase or preferred shares
and financial institutions and we've
wasted a bunch of time by having a plan
that did not make sense and probably
wasted some political capital as well
because it's now going to be hard to go
back to the well but it's gonna have to
be done and that's what will have to
happen to the extent that we've got a
global story here well it's pretty clear
that there are in fact large policy
spill overs that success by the United
States in recapitalizing these these
financial institutions would in fact do
a lot to take the pressure off Europe
and and conversely so there's a rumor
now that the that UK Treasuries is
contemplating recapitalization scheme
through financing of you know through
purchases of preferred shares that would
be a plus for the United States so we've
got a lot of policy interdependence and
a really very strong case for
coordinated plan for getting together
for having the the g7 get together and
and work out a coordinated program so
really tarp - or people who know what
I'm talking about it was the Troubled
Asset Relief Program which is really but
that's the Paulson flag we we were
trying to come up with better names for
it some people have called it suggested
Bailey Mae Alan Blinder we had a forum
Princeton Alan Blinder suggested hanky
panky in honor of the Treasury secretary
but anyway the but anyway hanky panky -
should be it should actually be an
international effort amazing stuff it's
it's it really is it it is a time when
we need really clear thinking and we
need really closer an international
coordination and it would be kind of
helpful if we actually had you know
administration that anybody believe in
any way it's a tough times exciting as a
as an academic economist I'm having a
great time as a citizen and and a bit of
an investor I'm terrified Thanks well
thank you very much
I think it would be best if we take
questions at the microphone because it
is hard so come up to the microphone
please and while you're getting yourself
organized in a long line there I'm going
to take the moderators prerogative and
ask a quick question that I hope you
it's going to be a difficult question so
answer it quickly
so that we can get to everybody else but
we're going to get through this mess one
way or another and so then the issue
that presents us sell itself next time
around is that there will always be a
shadow banking system there will always
be a shadow financial system that
operates outside the regulatory
environment that's that is provided by
the national supervision and regulation
system so there will always be dis
intermediation from the regulated and
transparent entities to those that are
less so or maybe not at all given that
that happens both domestically as well
as internationally what is the
implication of this for the next crisis
because there's going to be one unless
you can somehow avoid having any
linkages between the shadow financial
system and the regulated one I can come
in on that I mean all right so I mean
the back backdrop to Californians
comment is that we are talking about
extending regulation capital
requirements basically at the the line I
guess Barney Frank is using it and I I'm
using it too which is that if anything
it has to be rescued like a bank or to
be regulated like a bank and so we
should be studying this but then the
argument is well but you know then
people will just find ways of
financially innovating their way around
that um which I think the answer is yes
but it's question of quantity now not
there will always be some but how much
and the fact of the matter is
the Depression era banking regulations
largely contained the system for about
50 years it's only starting in the 1980s
that you start to see if a large-scale
growth of an end of the shadow banking
system parallel banking system and it's
not a coincidence that that starts to
happen at the time that you have also
have a basically deeply anti-regulatory
philosophy of government it's it's not
the Fed the private sector can't always
innovate its way around regulations or
at least can't always do it quickly it's
a question of whether you're prepared to
to do something so I think the the point
is yes there's always gonna be something
there's always going to be a bank in
some unregulated corner of the system
were the world so there's always going
to be a financial institution in Fiji
that isn't under the regulatory net but
I think you ought to be able to do
something I guess Catherines questions
have something to do with hedge funds
and I'll let that shadowy area outside
of the commercial banks and investment
banks I've been surprised to see the the
hedge funds from from time to time
demonized as if they were as much to
blame for the present crisis as as as
the big investments the big investment
banks borrow whether fantastic
misjudgments and irresponsibility most
of the hedge funds in most of the hedge
funds I think the the the the manager
has much of his or her own money in the
fund and the investors are very
sophisticated people who watched the
thing like a hawk my colleague colleague
Omar bday at Columbia suggests that
there shouldn't be well you might call
it a bipolar
a system in which you have a heavily
regulated subsystem that would be the
commercial banks and and maybe the
vestiges of the investment banks and and
they don't really have much not given
much rope at all to to hang themselves
and others and then the hedge funds and
else could be it would be completely
unregulated and you might have to pass
some sort of eligibility to be eligible
to be an investor in those but that
would be that would be where these
sources of investment then and and the
innovation finance would would come from
hi it seems like mark mark mark dot sir
Texas A&M real estate Research Center it
seems like part of the fundamental
problem is that home prices decline and
asset values go down and it spirals
why wouldn't we attack the problem
there's one or two million empty homes
in America we've been praying that maybe
a hurricane would land in Phoenix and
work its way through Las Vegas and into
Southern California somehow rather when
you have a million or two million too
many homes you either have to eliminate
supply or stimulate demand and all these
other things that seem to be putting
band-aids on an open wound here why why
wouldn't we give people a real tax
credit fundable a closing so that they
could buy homes why wouldn't we give
people a tax and save to buy homes like
we give people tax incentives to buy
computers when the technology market
gets soft when are we got i'm just
curious is that just not politically
feasible or is it too expensive but why
wouldn't we encourage people to buy
homes to get rid of this excess supply
thank you I'd like to take that one on I
thought part of the problem was that the
government started looking for ways to
make it possible for people who couldn't
afford it to own homes all this in the
name of the
of some newfangled conception that the
American Way is to own your own home
it's unamerican to live in a home that's
owned by a professional real estate
investor hey I couldn't see the point of
that in any way in any case it seems to
have been partly responsible for the
explosion of credit and the banking
system in recent years we've gotten
ourselves that the banking system got
themselves in a hole by by financing the
investment of homes that couldn't be
lived in if the price were to be
correspond to the cost of production and
and I don't see it as a solution to have
another round of subsidies and another
effort to raise the demand price for
houses I thought I thought that's how we
landed ourselves in trouble and I would
hate to see us go that way though I must
say when I try to when I try to
understand the the writings of Marty
Feldstein for example on this question
seems like he also wants to do something
to raise the price of houses some aspect
of the problem I think we've had an in
in in recent months is that it's taken
too long for the price of houses to fall
down to its fundamental level so this
all this overhang of excess supply of
houses that is adding to the reluctance
of home builders to produce any homes
that competing with people who were
already owning already existing homes
that want to sell if the price it had
had dropped as in of all raising
then we wouldn't have we wouldn't have
had the sharp contraction of the extra
contraction of output employment let me
just say that as a lot I don't agree
that the government played an important
role in this but the home prices by any
sort of fundamental measure ratio of
prices to rents ratio of prices to
median income ratio of prices you know
just real prices are still above
equilibrium levels they're still you
know 20 or so percent or more above
equilibrium levels nationally much more
than that in the in the most bubblicious
regions and I just don't think there's
any way you know this as some of my
colleagues say that you know the
proposals to support how home prices are
our proposals to deal with the with with
the the collapse of the internet bubble
by supporting the price of pets.com you
just can't do that and so that's not
that that would that would solve the
problem but it can't be done oh and you
scrum with Nate president thank you very
much for coming a quick question to Paul
going back to your chart where you add
asset prices on the vertical and asset
quantities on the horizontal and you
made a discrete distinction there in the
chart between demand for highly
leveraged institutions versus supply of
other investors and complicating that
chart of course is the fact that those
are not discrete units in other words we
have unfortunately the intermarriage
where we have demand and those highly
leveraged in its institutions they're
buying and selling they're eating their
own consuming it and when we look at
asset that commercial paper market or we
look at the CDs market they're supplying
and demanding at the same time which
increases the elasticity and causes a
further problem I'd like you to comment
on that and then you gave us the last
line recapitalize the banking system
well we've got the non-financial sector
out there the underlying assets and the
financial sector is really at supposed
to be servicing this bigger pie out
there the non
nancial sector so how can we clean it up
by just doing kind of the hairdo
and not talking about the fundamentals
okay it's a non financial sector yeah so
about the first yeah I mean it's it
thing is is there are all of these intra
intra financial sector claims and that's
that is you know making things even
worse I mean they the question of how
how could the fall of Lehman create as
much havoc as it did and that the answer
is is all the counterparty claims and
particularly the CES market and you know
what that's yeah we're we we have built
a very complex dangerous machine that we
don't understand and there's 50 trillion
or sixty trillion dollars worth of
intertwined claims that are very
difficult to deal with don't know what
more to say about that except that if if
we can you know what we hope that that
there will be a healing process if you
can get some capital into the system
about the non-financial look that's a it
is I think to some extent a different
problem though a very serious one if we
can get the financial system back to the
point where we aren't getting these all
these secondary consequences which by
the way is the way that financial crises
always end I mean in the end
government's always do end up
recapitalizing the financial system they
end up in Sweden taking over most of the
of the banking system for temporarily
and the savings and loan crisis we ended
up seizing most of the SNL's and and
recapitalizing them and in japan they
ended up buying preferred shares in the
banks so this is the way it always ends
and and Paulson was just sort of trying
to pretend that somehow we could be
different but but we aren't but then you
saw the real economy and I think we it's
pretty clear we were sliding into an
intensified recession I think we've been
in one since since December but we were
sliding into an intensified recession
even before the latest blow up in the
financial markets and so yes there ought
to be a stimulus package on top of all
this it's it's it's nasty all over but
but
so both and gotta be doing lots of stuff
and you know all I can say is a you know
we need a new Works Progress
Administration and let's hope that the
artwork is as good as it was in the
thirties
hello Brian Friedman GHP investment
advisors Denver Colorado one of the
purported benefits of securitization is
that supposedly the risk was distributed
to those best able to bear that risk and
it seems like magnets the exact opposite
has happened and I just wanted to get
your comment on why you think that was
and it appears to be a global phenomenon
and as a corollary do you think that
that the alternative bad redistribution
of risk to those least capable of
bearing it had something to do with the
very easy monetary policy between 2003
and 5 thank you all right let's just
point that's a lot that's a lot of
things packed together yeah I mean our
belief that the self policing markets
would ensure that things were done then
in a rational way doesn't seem to work
out too well all I can say is that there
seemed to be structural it once once you
have some some naivete on the part of
investors
I guess the PT Barnum sucker born every
minute theory of financial markets then
all kinds of bad things can happen once
you have securitization and the yeah I
mean and everyone should all read the
old paper by Andy Lowe at MIT on how how
to set up a hedge fund that that he
calls of capital decimation partners
that does nothing except take on risk
and is almost guaranteed to make a lot
of money for the for the managers even
though it's going to blow up in the end
and that's I think what happened low
interest rate but I don't think there
was an alternative to the low interest
rate policy I I think that there's a lot
that that Greenspan could have done
limit the financial excesses but you
know I if you either probably did
contribute but I don't know what else
what else you could have done it we we
had a real risk of a deflationary spiral
in the early years of this decade as we
will again probably next year and low
interest rates too what you have to do
but then you have to also police the
consequences well I certainly agree that
that this mystique of diversification
was one of the great fallacies of recent
years and of course what was
unsatisfactory about about about this
this thinking was that to have a
diversified portfolio of bad assets and
assets that are whose values whose
values are tied together with one
another dozens to protect the investor
from systemic risk and look committee
one of the major lessons that we have to
learn from this experience is going to
be difficult it's going to require a lot
of rethinking a lot of hard work but I
think one of the major lessons we have
to learn is that in an economy that's
capitalist to any appreciable extent
investors have to think strategically
they have to think about what's going to
happen if everybody is making loans in
the directions that we're making loans
what will that do to relative prices
what's what will happen if the rosy
scenario that we're all operating on is
not the right scenario what if there's a
bad scenario out there
that has a rather significant
probability of occurring how are we
going to protect ourselves against the
possibility of the bad scenario there's
all time the financial engineering and
risk assessment and risk risk management
that in that entire literature has
encouraged people to believe that by
following certain mechanical models they
have banished all the problems of
ambiguity uncertainty imperfect
knowledge that necessarily exists in a
capitalist economy so we're learning now
that one of the lessons we have to draw
I think is that that way of thinking is
not only willfully insufficient from
some sort of scientific point of view
but it's dangerous for investors and for
the financial system and for the economy
as a whole
yes prices of the paper valuation and
the accounting of it
I would since we're really talking here
in a about you know in effect complex
products and fixed income that isn't
where the cash flows aren't fixed can
you make any you've said it's central to
the problem can you make any comments at
all about how we get to a better way of
doing it and things you might talk about
are when the first type prices come out
what are you going to think about them
to what extent does Europe now have an
over valuation problem with its
accounting and how long-term are we
going to reform the accounting
profession which may need some
considerable work to put it mildly could
you just introduce yourself oh yeah I'm
Andrew Hodge ba III I think the answer
is no not sure I mean I have no idea but
you know just but I think the at least
part of this has to do with the whole
question of mark-to-market and all that
and I don't think that I don't think the
the accounting is going to make a
difference right now that you know the
people who think that that what if we
can put mark-to-market on one side and
and have some different accounting that
that will make things look better
because balance sheets will look better
but you know the fact of the matter is
right now banks don't trust each other's
balance sheets that's what that's what
the Ted spread which was I think 3.93
this morning is telling us and and so
it's not gonna not gonna help any and I
don't know the accounting is we do a big
project now counting us is part of this
problem but you know right now actually
it is not an issue because nobody
believes the numbers anyway I'm Bob crow
I'm the editor of business economics I'm
also a director of the bank of the
Orient and professor Phelps ending
comments brought to mind a what seems to
me to be a strange paradox
you called for the the banking system
presumably commercial banks included to
do more lending for innovation as
opposed to more conventional lending
including a lot of investment in paper
and so forth and so on
well the paradox that I see is this if
we did this we would absolutely get
dinged by bank examiners on the basis on
the grounds of safety and soundness
because lending to lending to an
organization that doesn't have a real
balance sheet doesn't have a profit
record would would be likely to subject
us to a great deal of criticism if we
did very much of it on the other hand
commercial banking system is perfectly
capable of going
and obviously has done and a slew of
subprime mortgages that they don't get
criticized for by the examiners why
because they immediately package them up
securitize them send them off to
somebody else so the examiners don't pay
any attention to this instead they see
that we that the commercial bank has
acquired triple-a rated assets by buying
back bundles of the same kinds of
mortgages that they just sent out so the
what I'd like you to comment on is
whether or not the kind of supervision
we have which focuses on individual
institutions is tremendously outdated
and whether the role of examiner should
be more on systemic risk in addition to
individual individual firm risk so any
thoughts on the matter Wow
I think it's a different kind of
supervision you do still need to have
some people of examining the individual
banks but the other thing that I think
there's a rules vs. discretion issue
that if if there's some kind of overall
assessment of systemic risk it's going
to be very hard to make that stick I
mean not sure if I'm answering your
question but I think it's appropriate I
mean the suppose we had had an agency
that was in a position to to say look
this whole class of stuff subprime
mortgages is vulnerable you know we may
have a housing bubble like all of that
supposed that such an agency had been
operative in 2005 what would it have
done and the answer I can tell you is it
would have been it would have said there
is no problem because housing prices are
justified by fundamentals and this all
the stuff is sound because they were
under
that was very largely the conventional
wisdom at the time those of us who were
trying to say look this this something
is way out of whack here were we're
dismissed as as being just you know
excessively worried if not politically
motivated I've got a whole stash you
know people saying the only reason you
say there's a housing bubble is because
you hate bush so it's a if that that's a
very hard thing to do the the same
psychology that leads to the bubbles
also tends to make oversight in such
cases very very hard which is a case for
saying that well actually what we just
need is better rules for for the
individual institutions although I I
don't know how we deal with the with the
ratings agency problem it's there
there's not a thing as this is not new
every financial crisis I've seen in the
past
almost thirty years now has involved the
rating agencies being behind the curve
the reason rating agencies essentially
being procyclical and and it's hard to
think that that's going to change even
after this one I agree that we're gonna
have to rethink oversight and the range
of rating agencies and accounting all
this is going to have to be a rethought
and and I come back to the proposal of
my colleague MRP day that there has to
be a a hard core banking sector
commercial banks I suppose that are
highly regulated don't really have any
latitude for judgment and strategic
thinking at all that wouldn't be their
game but then we're going we're going to
have to have banks that would develop
the expertise to be able to finance
alternative energy investments that
we're going to need and want in the
future all sorts of all sorts of
forward-looking investment of business
activity business investment projects
are going to deserve that to be invested
in by some sort of bank like entities
and I don't know how to figure out hmm
III can't anticipate all all the
problems from here to there but for sure
we're gonna have to move in that
direction we can't have a banking sector
that's totally occupied with with
mortgages it seems to me ok can I weigh
in on the after I think this I the hard
core I guess hard core of tightly
regulated banks and I guess the rest of
soft core whatever the more or less we
have that we have a commercial banks we
have with insured deposits we have a you
know stop that that that is reasonably
tightly regulated and the problem is
that the soft core the penumbra the
shadow stuff turns out to bring down
you know you can't destroy the world so
it's not clear that having that kind of
dual system works and we're where this
is this is the problem with with looking
forward and bank regulation it it does
not appear that it's safe to have a any
large sector that's outside the
regulatory framework I know that there
are a lot of questions still out there
but I'm afraid that we're running
significantly over time so at this point
I'd like to thank professors Phelps and
Krugman for joining us in this session
and
in addition
in addition I would like to thanks Sarah
Potter and fact set research systems for
sponsoring this session thanks Sarah
Potter and factset research session